This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. When you build a home or design a building, there are many alarms you might want to install. We have devices that beep and blare when something is wrong. They notify us about problems. They alert us to threats. In the long course of evolution, nature has built similar alarms into us.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔。当你建造房屋或设计大楼时，你可能会安装许多警报器。我们有设备，在出问题时会发出哔哔声和尖锐的警报。它们向我们通报问题。它们向我们发出威胁警报。在漫长的进化历程中，大自然也在我们体内构建了类似的警报。
Warnings go off inside our heads when we are about to do something that can be dangerous. I part 3 2 1! Our internal alarm systems can also be activated by situations that are not dangerous, but are still stressful, like performing at a piano recital, or public speaking, or going to a party where we don't know anyone. Quarantine was good, though. No. Great. But recently, I have been going to dinner again. Did I just say I've been going to dinner again? Should I give them more details or should I die?
当我们即将做出可能危险的事情时，警告就会在我们的脑海中响起。我，第3、2、1部分！我们的内部警报系统也可能被那些并不危险但仍然充满压力的情境激活，比如弹钢琴独奏、公开演讲，或者去一个谁也不认识的派对。不过，隔离挺好的。不。太棒了。但最近，我又开始去吃晚饭了。我是刚说我又开始去吃晚饭了吗？我是该给他们更多细节，还是该直接死掉？
The paradox, of course, is that the alarms meant to help us can also sometimes destabilize us, especially when they become deafening. This week on Hidden Brain, learning to listen differently to the alarms inside your head. Life is full of adversity, challenge, and uncertainty. Think back to the last time you had a child come to you in tears or a friend who had just received a difficult medical diagnosis. Think back to the last time you were worried about something. So worried, you could barely think straight. At City University of New York Hunter College, psychologist and neuroscientist Tracy Dennis Tawari studies these voices of alarm inside our heads and how to deal
当然，这里的悖论在于，旨在帮助我们的警报有时也会让我们崩溃，尤其是当它们变得震耳欲聋时。本周的《隐藏的大脑》，学习以不同的方式倾听你内心的警报。生活充满逆境、挑战和不确定性。回想一下你上一次看到孩子哭着来找你，或者某个朋友刚刚拿到一份棘手的医疗诊断书的情景。回想一下你上一次为某事担忧的情景。担忧到几乎无法清晰思考。在纽约市立大学亨特学院，心理学家兼神经科学家特雷西·丹尼斯·塔瓦里（Tracy Dennis Tawari）研究了我们内心的这些警报声以及如何应对
with them. Tracy Dennis Tawari, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shankar, it's great to be with you. Tracy, some years ago you found yourself teaching your son how to ride a bicycle. I understand you were in upstate New York. Can you describe what the day was like and your hopes when you set out? Right, so that's my son, Covey, and he was about nine years old at the time. And we're raising our kids in Manhattan, and so, you know, he's a city kid, and we had not gotten around to teaching him how to ride a bike. Now, we were upstate, and so I just thought, okay, now is the time. And I said, okay, Covey, let's go out and start learning. And he seemed game for it.
它们。特雷西·丹尼斯·塔瓦里，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，香卡，很高兴能和你在一起。特雷西，几年前你发现自己在教儿子骑自行车。据我所能了解，你当时在纽约州北部。能描述一下那天的天气以及你出发时的期望吗？好的，那是我的儿子科维（Covey），当时他大约九岁。我们在曼哈顿抚养孩子，所以，你知道的，他是个城市小孩，我们一直没抽出时间教他骑自行车。现在我们在纽约州北部，所以我想，好吧，时机到了。我说：“好吧，科维，我们出去开始学吧。”他看起来也跃跃欲试。
Our friend's Raj and Laura had lent us an old Gremlin BMX. So we had this big old clunky bike. I took him to a gravelly hill. And I just started trying to teach him. And he was doing great. He was riding. And he was really doing it. But he started to say, you know, I'm afraid,
我们的朋友拉杰（Raj）和劳拉（Laura）借给我们一辆旧的格雷姆林（Gremlin）小轮 BMX 自行车。所以我们有了这辆又大又笨重的旧自行车。我把他带到一个铺满碎石的山坡上。然后我开始尝试教他。他做得很好。他会骑了。他真的做到了。但他开始说，你知道的，我害怕，
I'm going to fall and he really wanted to throw in the towel. So he's staying upright on the bike, but he's also very nervous and unbeknownst to you, your phone happens to be recording while you're giving him a pep talk about his ability to ride this bike. Now it was a windy day, but I want to hear some of the exchange that you had with your son, and I think it's fair to say that you were frustrated. Alright, let's go up, Kubby. You know what? I'm going to start giving up. I'm doing my best to be supportive and you're nothing but a grouch.
我要摔倒了，他真的很想放弃。所以他虽然在自行车上保持平衡，但他也非常紧张，而你不知道的是，就在你给他打气、鼓励他有能力骑这辆自行车时，你的手机恰好在录音。那天风很大，但我想听听你和儿子的一些对话，而且我觉得可以公平地说，当时你很沮丧。好吧，我们上去吧，科维。你知道吗？我要开始放弃了。我尽力在支持你，而你却像个大发脾气的怪人。
I'm enjoying you. No, Kubby, you're doing great. You're just complaining every second of the way. I love you, Charlie. You're doing great. You're just complaining every second of the way. You're doing amazing. Why are you so negative about it? You're in on go. Bring it up. That's cool. You are not scared.
我很享受和你在一起。不，科维，你做得很好。你只是每分每秒都在抱怨。我爱你，查理。你做得很好。你只是每分每秒都在抱怨。你做得太棒了。你为什么对此这么消极？你准备好了。把它提起来。太酷了。你一点也不害怕。
There's nothing to be scared about. You did it perfectly. You haven't fallen once. I should knock you down. I think you're falling. Get over it, Covey. Honestly, there's nothing. You're just talking to yourself.
没什么好害怕的。你做得完美极了。你连一次都没摔倒过。我应该把你推倒。我觉得你要摔倒了。克服它吧，科维。老实说，真的没什么。你只是在自言自语。
You're being scared. You're right. And I don't know why. You're crushing it. You're so good. You're so good at it. And you're just talking yourself into this crazy, like I'm scared. You're not. You're doing awesome. You haven't even fallen. You haven't even gotten the silver rose. Come on. I think you have lots of love here. You've got to get your head together, man. So at one point, Tracy, he says, I'm scared and you say you are not scared. I want you to put yourself back in your shoes that day. Now, I know you may have revised how you were thinking after you heard this clip, but I want you to put yourself back in your shoes that day in that moment.
你在害怕。你说得对。我不知道为什么。你太棒了。你太厉害了。你太擅长这个了。而你却一直在自己吓自己，搞得好像我很害怕一样。你才不害怕呢。你表现得棒极了。你甚至都没摔倒。你连个银星都没拿。来吧。我觉得你这里有很多爱。你得振作起来，老兄。所以在某个时刻，特雷西，他说我很害怕，而你说你一点也不害怕。我想让你回到那天的情境中。现在，我知道在你听到这段录音后，你可能会改变自己当时的思绪，但我希望你回到那天那一刻的心境中。
Paint me a picture of how you were trying to help your child deal with his fears. Oh, yes, and that was very painful to listen to. When he was working on riding the bike, it was so puzzling when in the face of success, he kept on expressing fear and anxiety and wasn't able to track his gains he was making. And the more fear and anxiety he expressed, the more anxious I was becoming. And I think I felt like this was a sign that, oh gosh, is he going to have a hard time persisting through other challenges or things that make him scared? And so I think essentially, I was anxious that his anxiety, learning to ride a bike, was going to reflect or play into some larger vulnerability in his life. So like any parent, I felt concerned for his well-being and I think that was driving my frustration and my strong reaction to him.
给我描绘一下你当时是如何试图帮助孩子克服恐惧的。哦，是的，听这段录音真的很痛苦。当他练习骑自行车时，最让人困惑的是，在面对成功时，他却不断表达恐惧和焦虑，无法觉察到自己取得的进步。他表达的恐惧和焦虑越多，我也变得越焦虑。我想我觉得这是一种迹象，哦天哪，他以后是不是很难坚持面对其他挑战或让他害怕的事情？所以我想，本质上我很焦虑，担心他学骑自行车时表现出的焦虑，会反映或转化为他生活中的某种更大脆弱性。所以像任何父母一样，我为他的状况感到担忧，我想正是这一点推动了我的沮丧情绪以及我对他的强烈反应。
So as we were researching this episode, we came by the work of the author Julie Liddcott Haymes. She's a former dean at Stanford University and one of her best-selling books is titled How to Raise an Adult, a Break Free of the Overparenting Trap, and Prepare Your Kid for Success. Here's something she wants said. If the world is less safe, which it really is not statistically, but even if it was, don't we need our kids to be stronger and more capable to face what awaits them outside of our homes? If things are less safe out there, we need to be raising warriors, not fragile, weak pieces of veal, who will
因此，在我们研究这一期节目时，我们偶然看到了作家朱莉·利德科特-海姆斯（Julie Lythcott-Haims）的作品。她是斯坦福大学的前院长，她最畅销的书之一是《如何培养成年人：摆脱过度育儿的陷阱，为孩子的成功做好准备》（How to Raise an Adult: Break Free of the Overparenting Trap, and Prepare Your Kid for Success）。这是她曾说过的一段话。如果世界变得不那么安全——从统计学上讲它其实并没有变得不安全，但即使它真的变不安全了——难道我们不更需要我们的孩子们变得更坚强、更有能力去面对等待着他们的家门之外的世界吗？如果外面的世界变得不那么安全，我们需要培养的是勇士，而不是娇嫩脆弱、不堪一击的维也纳小牛肉，
be slaughtered by what the world brings to them. So Tracy, I heard you trying to do this for your son. He was telling you that he was scared and you were telling him be a warrior. That's exactly right. And those, you know, her words really resonate, I think, with, you know, me thinking back to how I was feeling in that moment, I think it resonates with many of us parents who see that the world is very different in many ways from the world we grew up in, and we're deeply concerned that we can help launch our children into this new world in a way that sets them up for success and happiness and well-being. So, this is one way in which our culture recommends dealing with the alarms that go off inside our heads.
他们会被世界带给他们的一切无情吞噬。所以特雷西，我听到你当时就是这样对待你的儿子的。他告诉你他很害怕，而你告诉他要当一个勇士。完全正确。而且那些——你知道的，她的那些话真的引发了我的共鸣，我想，这让我想起了我当时的心情，我想这也引起了我们许多父母的共鸣。我们看到这个世界在许多方面与我们成长时的世界截然不同，我们深感担忧，希望能以一种为他们铺平成功、幸福和健康之路的方式，将我们的孩子们送入这个新世界。所以，这是我们的文化建议我们处理内心警报的一种方式。
We say, you know, be brave, ignore the alarms, full speed ahead. But there's also another way, and you've come by this yourself in your work as a college professor. I understand Tracy starting a few years ago, you noticed a change in your students in terms of how they were handling challenging situations. Can you talk to me about that? I've been a professor for moving up on 20 years now, and really I think it was just maybe over the past five, six, seven years. There seemed to be quite a shift in how students were reacting to challenges.
我们说，你知道的，要勇敢，忽视警报，全速前进。但还有另一种方式，你在自己作为大学教授的工作中也遇到了这种情况。据我了解，特雷西，从几年前开始，你注意到学生们在应对充满挑战的情境时的态度发生了变化。你能跟我谈谈这个吗？我当教授已经快20年了，真的，我想大概也就是在过去五、六年、七年里。学生们对挑战的反应似乎发生了相当大的转变。
And especially with our graduate students, and especially in the field of clinical psychology, that is, people who are becoming our future therapists and clinical researchers, when I was getting my degree, there was this idea that you throw yourself into these challenging situations, whether it's science or therapy. And you have to push through, and you have to show that there's a level of grit and determination that you can build on and sort of, you know, slowly become a professional. And what I noticed in this era of students is there was less belief in their ability to
特别是我们的研究生，尤其是在临床心理学领域——也就是那些将成为我们未来的治疗师和临床研究人员的人——当我获得学位时，有一种观点认为，你应该全身心投入到这些充满挑战的情境中，无论是科学研究还是心理治疗。你必须挺过去，你必须展现出一种坚韧和决心的水平，以此为基础，并逐渐成长为一名专业人士。而我在这代学生身上注意到的是，他们对自己能力的信任有所下降，
cope with some of these challenges that were being thrown their way. I think you see this trend really being crystallized in the idea of safe spaces. One way that students have tried to create a more comfortable environment for themselves is to really argue that, well, you know, if there is an offensive opinion, if there is an upsetting content, if, you know, we see this on campus is all over the country that there are speakers who might come to campus and have some, you know, for some really offensive opinions or there's a very vigorous debate that a speaker or a number of speakers might be taking part in. I see students much less prepared or interested or motivated to actually go and take part in these debates
觉得无力应对迎面而来的这些挑战。我认为你看到这种趋势在“安全空间”（safe spaces）的概念中真正变得具象化了。学生们试图为自己营造一个更舒适环境的一种方式，就是提出这样的观点：好吧，你知道的，如果有冒犯性的观点，如果有令人不安的内容，如果——你知道的，我们在全国各地的校园里都看到这种情况，有些演讲者可能会来到校园，持有某种——你知道的，对某些人来说非常冒犯的观点，或者有一场非常激烈的辩论，某个或某些演讲者可能会参与其中。我发现学生们远没有那么准备充分、没有那么感兴趣、也没有那么有动力去实际参与这些辩论，
in these difficult conversations and these uncomfortable experiences and emotions and instead really ask to be shielded and protected from them. At one point, Tracy, I understand that a professor at your university was alleged to have engaged in inappropriate behavior and he eventually resigned. Can you tell me what happened and the effect it had on students? It was a very painful experience for our community and part of the pain of that experience was that there was awareness and there was not enough advocacy and protection of the students.
参与这些困难的对话以及这些令人不舒服的体验和情绪，相反，他们真正要求的是被屏蔽和保护，免受这些影响。特雷西，据我所了解，在某个时刻，你所在大学的一名教授被指控有不当行为，他最终辞职了。你能告诉我发生了什么事以及它对学生产生了什么影响吗？这对我们的社区来说是一次非常痛苦的经历。这种痛苦的一部分原因在于，当时虽然有所觉察，但对学生的倡导和保护并不够。
And one thing that I was, as we were processing this as a community and really tried to engage in those conversations, one thing that I noticed that surprised me in some ways is that there were direct requests from some students to not give them information without first sort of filtering it for them. from some students to not give them information without first sort of filtering it for them. For example, there was an article that was published,
而当我作为社区的一员在处理这件事、并真正试图参与到这些对话中时，我注意到了一件在某些方面让我感到惊讶的事，那就是有些学生直接提出要求：不要在没有事先为他们进行某种过滤的情况下，就把信息提供给他们。比如，当时曾发表过一篇文章，
and some students felt very let down and unsupported because we faculty did not tell them that this article was coming out or helped them process it before they were able to read it themselves. And this really struck me because it occurred to me that what students were asking for was a sort of way of processing emotions so that they didn't have to actually process it out of the social support net. It seemed to me that the emotions they might experience
有些学生感到非常失望和缺乏支持，因为我们教职员工没有告诉他们这篇文章即将发表，也没有在他们自己阅读之前帮助他们消化这些内容。这真的让我很震撼，因为我突然意识到，学生们所要求的是一种处理情绪的方式，好让他们不必实际在社会支持网络之外去处理情绪。在我看来，他们在阅读这篇文章以及接触到令人不安和痛苦的信息时可能会体验到的情绪，
in reading this article and being exposed to uncomfortable and painful information, that they felt that those emotions might do them harm. So the students were looking essentially for a trigger warning? In a way, it was a trigger warning. And of course, trigger warnings began as a way to really help folks who were struggling
他们觉得这些情绪可能会对他们造成伤害。所以学生们本质上是在寻找某种“触发警告”（trigger warning）？在某种程度上，这确实是一个触发警告。当然，触发警告最初的形式，是为了真正帮助那些与创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）作斗争、过去曾遭受创伤的人。当他们接触到与创伤相关的信息时，当时的设想是，好吧，让我们给他们一个准备的机会，并在必要时避开这些信息。然而，就在我们的学生要求设立安全空间和触发警告的同时，特雷西一直在密切关注关于这些顺应措施效果的科学研究。数据仍在源源不断地涌现，但在2021年的一项研究中，研究人员找来一些人，让他们阅读一个场景，
with post-traumatic stress disorder, who had a trauma in their past. And when they were exposed to trauma-related information, the thought was, well, let's give them an opportunity to prepare and avoid the information, if necessary. But even as our students were asking for safe spaces and trigger warnings, Tracy had one eye on the scientific research on the effects of these accommodations. The data are still coming in, but in one study from 2021, people were brought in and they were asked to actually read about a scenario
这个场景可能具有挑战性，对某些人来说在情感上具有挑战性或令人不安。其中一半人收到了关于该场景的触发警告，即他们可能会读到一些让他们心烦意乱的内容，而另一半人则没有收到这个警告。你在研究中发现的是，收到触发警告的人实际上表现出更高水平的焦虑，特别是如果他们抱有这样一种信念：
that may have been challenging, emotionally challenging, or upsetting for some people. And half of that group, they gave a trigger warning about it that you might be reading about something that will upset you and the other half did not receive that warning. What you found in this study was that people who received the trigger warning actually showed higher levels of anxiety, especially if they held this belief
即情绪会对自己造成伤害。我的意思是，这难道不会让人对触发警告的有效性产生质疑吗？这当然会引发质疑。而且存在一种非常强烈的可能性，那就是通过发出触发警告，我们实际传达给人们的信息是：前方会有令人心烦意乱的事情发生。我们认为你未必能应付得了。如果你感到情绪困难，它们可能会伤害你。所以，触发警告这一事实本身，
that emotions can do them harm. I mean, doesn't that raise questions about the efficacy of trigger warnings? It certainly raises questions. And there's a very strong possibility that by giving trigger warnings, the message we're actually sending to people is that there's something upsetting coming up. We don't think you can necessarily handle it. And if you feel difficult emotions, they might do you harm. So that the very fact of trigger warnings
正在围绕困难情绪构建这样一种叙事、这样一个故事。而大多数情绪科学和临床科学实际上都会指出，这是适得其反的。美国文化，以及世界各地日益增多的文化，都在两种相互冲突的叙事之间撕裂。一种叙事说：如果你对某事感到害怕，控制恐惧的方法就是消除那个让你害怕的事物。
is creating this narrative, this story around difficult emotions. That most emotion science and clinical science will actually say is counterproductive. American culture, and increasingly cultures around the world are torn between two competing narratives. One says, if you're frightened about something, the way to get your fears under control is to eliminate the thing that's frightening you.
另一种叙事说：忽视你的焦虑。如果你感到焦虑，就告诉自己：我一点也不焦虑。克服它吧。当我们回来时，特雷西将探讨我们应该如何处理内心警报的科学原理。你收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，
The other narrative says, dismiss your anxiety. If you feel anxious, tell yourself, I'm not anxious. Get over it. When we come back, Tracy explores the science of how we should deal with the alarms inside our head. You're listening to Hidden Brain,
我是香卡·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·韦丹塔。特雷西·尼斯·塔瓦里是纽约市立大学亨特学院的心理学家和神经科学家。和许多其他观察家一样，特雷西注意到在应对恐惧时存在两种思想流派。一种流派说：让我们保证人们的安全。人们感到的焦虑指向了他们正在面临的威胁。
I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Tracey Dennis Tawari is a psychologist and neuroscientist at CUNY Hunter College. Like many other observers, Tracey has noticed two schools of thought when it comes to dealing with our fears. One says, let's keep people safe. The anxieties people have pointed to the threats they are confronting.
如果我们想减少焦虑，就应该减少威胁。另一种思想流派说：问题不在于世界，问题在于你。你的警报太敏感了。你应该忽略这些警报。现在毫无疑问，许多人患有与焦虑相关的精神障碍，但特雷西的关注点较少放在临床病症上，而是更多地放在我们作为一种文化看待焦虑的方式上。
If we want to reduce the anxieties, we should reduce the threats. The other school of thought says, the problem is not with the world. The problem is with you. Your alarms are too sensitive. You should ignore the alarms. Now there's no question that many people suffer from anxiety related mental disorders, but Tracy's focus was less on clinical conditions and more on the way we think about anxiety as a culture.
所以你开始对这两种模型进行大量的思考和研究，并且你获得了一个重要的洞察：焦虑究竟像其中一种思想流派所让你相信的那样是一个性格缺陷，还是像另一种思想流派所让你相信的那样是一种无法忍受的创伤？特雷西，你对焦虑本质的洞察是什么？情绪从根本上说是具有功能的。它们具有适应性功能。实际上，这并不是一个新观点。达尔文进化论的三分之一篇幅恰好专门用于探讨情绪。这是他三部曲中的第三本书，名为《人类和动物的表达情绪》（The Expression of the Emotions in Man and Animals）。所以，想想积极情绪和消极情绪的双刃剑效应。
So you started to do a lot of thinking and research about these two models and you came to an important insight about whether anxiety was a character flaw as one school of thought would have you believe, or it was an unbearable trauma as another school of thought would have you believe. What was your insight Tracy about the nature of anxiety? Emotions are fundamentally functional. They have adaptive functions. And we actually, this is not a new idea. It so happens that a third of Darwin's theory of evolution has actually devoted to emotions. It's the third book in his trilogy is called the expression of emotion in man and animals. So think about the double-edged sword of both positive and negative emotions.
因此，当你将这个功能模型应用到焦虑的研究中时，它如何改变了你对焦虑的理解？它彻底改变了我的看法，因为我落入了我们许多人都会陷入的语言陷阱，那就是当我说“哦，我有焦虑”或者“这个人有焦虑”时，我实际上是在传达某人患有焦虑症。所以我把焦虑这种情绪与一种疾病完全混为一谈了。这确实是我获得重大洞察的时刻，因为焦虑情绪并不是一种疾病。焦虑是一种情绪，它可以在一个广谱上延伸，从我们胃里的蝴蝶般翻腾的感觉到强烈的恐慌感。
So, when you apply this functional model to the study of anxiety, how did it change the meaning of anxiety for you? It changed it radically because I'd fallen into this language trap that I think many of us have, which is that when I say, oh, I have anxiety or this person has anxiety, I'm actually communicating that someone has an anxiety disorder. So I'm completely conflating the emotion of anxiety with a disorder. And this was really the moment of my big insight because the emotion of anxiety is not a disorder. Anxiety is an emotion and it can very long a spectrum from butterflies in our stomach to strong feelings of panic.
只有当我们随着时间推移应对焦虑的方式导致了功能受损时，才会确诊为焦虑症。也就是说，我们为应对焦虑而采取的行动正在造成更多的伤害，导致我们在工作上出现问题、在人际关系中出现问题、影响我们的健康选择。也许，也许你在用药物进行自我治疗，你在做一系列的事情来应对焦虑。这实际上造成了更多的伤害并构成了阻碍。只有到那时，我们才会被诊断为焦虑症。所以，当我们说我们现在社会正经历一场焦虑危机时，
An anxiety disorder is only diagnosed when our ways of coping with anxiety over time are causing functional impairment. So that the actions we're taking to handle that anxiety are causing more harm, causing us to have problems at work, have problems in our relationships, our affecting our health choices. Maybe, maybe you're self-medicating with drugs, you're doing a series of things to cope with anxiety. That's really causing more harm and is getting in the way. That's when we're diagnosed with an anxiety disorder. So when we say we have a crisis of anxiety in our society right now,
我们真正想说的是，我们在应对焦虑的方式上正经历一场危机。特雷西接触到了一些研究，这些研究提出了这样的问题：如果你不再把焦虑完全看作一种疾病，而是开始把它看作一种需要去处理的情绪，会发生什么？这是耶鲁大学儿童研究中心的埃利·利博维茨（Eli Lebowitz）及其同事的研究。这个观点是：当我们家族中有一个焦虑的孩子时，存在一种强烈的倾向——我想高达97%的情况下——我们会试图顺应和迁就这种焦虑。
what we really mean is that we have a crisis in the ways that we're coping with anxiety. Tracy came by some research that asked, what happens if you stop thinking about anxiety exclusively as a disorder and start thinking of it as an emotion to be worked with? And this is the work of Ellie Liebowitz and his colleagues at the Yale Child Study Center. It's this idea that when we have a child in our family who's anxious, there is a strong tendency, I think upwards of 97% of the time, we will try to accommodate that anxiety.
这意味着我们想要安抚那个孩子。我们想要帮助他们避开那些会引发焦虑的情境，因为当然了，我们作为父母——除了显然我们在教孩子骑自行车的时候除外——对于我来说，我们做父母的，你知道的，只是希望我们的孩子们感觉好一点，我们想安慰他们，我们想让他们安心。但这种针对焦虑的顺应迁就也是有代价的。
And that means we want to reassure that child. We want to help them avoid the anxiety provoking situations because of course we parents, except apparently when we're teaching a kid to ride a bike, for me, we parents, you know, we just want our kids to feel better, we want to comfort them, we want to reassure them. But this accommodation when it comes to anxiety has a price tag.
这些顺应不仅没有让孩子们变得不那么焦虑，反而似乎让孩子们变得更加焦虑了。因此，研究人员尝试了一种新方法。于是，利博维茨和同事们创造了一种新的干预方法，叫做 SPACE——针对焦虑儿童的父母支持疗法（Supportative Parenting for Anxious Childhood Emotions）。他们做了一件非常巧妙的事情。他们招募了一组确诊患有焦虑症的儿童。其中一半的孩子接受了金标准认知行为疗法（CBT），
Instead of making kids less anxious, the accommodations seem to make the children more anxious. So the researchers tried something new. And so, LEBowitz and colleagues created a new intervention called space, support of parenting for anxious children. And they did something really elegant. They had a group of kids with anxiety disorders, diagnosed. And to half of that group, they gave them gold standard cognitive behavioral therapy,
这是针对焦虑症的最佳治疗方法之一。而对于另一半孩子，他们没有接受任何治疗。相反，他们教导父母停止过度迁就孩子的焦虑，开始帮助孩子们克服焦虑。那是什么意思？对于一个社交焦虑、再也不想去学校、晚上不想一个人睡觉的孩子来说，顺应就是：你知道的，你对孩子说，啊，你知道的，学校让他们太难过了，那我们今天就让他在家呆着吧。
which is one of the best therapeutic approaches for anxiety disorders. To the other half of the group, they gave the kids no therapy. And instead, they taught parents to stop over accommodating their children's anxiety and to start helping their children work through anxiety. What does that mean? A accommodation for a child who's socially anxious and doesn't want to go to school anymore, doesn't want to sleep alone at night, you know, you say, ah, you know, the school makes them so upset, let's let them stay home today.
哦，你知道的，他们害怕黑暗。那我们今晚让他们睡在大人的床上吧。这种顺应会随着时间不断重复。因此，SPACE干预法教导父母做的是：停止这种迁就，转而缓慢而稳定地帮助孩子们去接触这些会引发焦虑的情境，并逐步克服它们。这样一来，缓慢地，孩子得到了帮助重新回到学校。缓慢地，孩子得到了帮助和支持，能在晚上独自在自己的房间睡觉了。在这项研究结束时，当你比较孩子们的焦虑严重程度，
And oh, you know, they're scared of the dark. Let's let them sleep in the parents bed tonight. And this accommodation is repeated over time. And so what parents in the space intervention we're taught to do was to stop the accommodation and instead slowly and steadily help their kids to engage with these anxiety-provoking situations and slowly work through them. So that slowly, the child is helped to get back to school. Slowly the child is helped and supported to sleep in their own bed alone at night. And at the end of this study, when you compared the children's anxiety severity,
如果你将直接接受CBT治疗的孩子组，与没有接受任何治疗但其父母接受了SPACE干预的孩子组进行比较，这两组孩子在减少焦虑症状方面表现出了完全相同的改善水平。父母们感到了更少的压力，而且父母们也确实对儿童焦虑表现出了更少的过度迁就。每当听到刺耳的警报响起时，我们的本能反应通常是两件事之一：要么把它关掉，要么往相反方向逃跑。特雷西说，如果我们不去试图压抑它或逃避它，而是带着好奇心去与内心的警报互动，会发生什么？
if you compare the group that the children received CBT directly versus the group of kids who receive no therapy, but their parents received the space intervention, those kids showed exactly the same level of gain in terms of reduced anxiety symptoms. The parents felt less stress, and the parents did indeed show less over accommodation of childhood anxiety. Our stock responses when we hear a blaring alarm is to do one of two things, turn it off or run in the opposite direction. Tracy said, instead of trying to suppress it or flee from it, what happens if you engage
如果你对你的焦虑说：我看到你正试图告诉我一些重要的事。我真的很想听听你的意见。帮我理解你。换句话说，特雷西问：如果你把焦虑当成朋友对待，会发生什么？如果你把焦虑当成朋友对待，会发生什么？没错。所以，焦虑是对不确定未来的担忧。现在，它感觉像是恐惧，我们经常将两者等同起来。但恐惧是关于你正面临的当前威胁的确定知识，与此相反，焦虑与现在毫无关系。它所做的是让我们成为通往未来的心理时间旅行者，未来可能会发生糟糕的事，
with your alarms with curiosity? What happens if you tell your anxiety? I see you are trying to tell me something important. I really want to hear you out. Help me understand you. In other words, Tracy asked what happens if you treat anxiety like a friend. happens if you treat anxiety like a friend. That's right. So anxiety is apprehension about the uncertain future. Now it feels like fear and we often equate the two. But while fear is about really certain knowledge that there's a present threat you're facing, anxiety in contrast has nothing to do with the present. What it does is it makes us into mental time travelers into the future where something bad could happen,
但也可能会发生美好的事。这依然是有可能的。所以我可能会感到焦虑，也许我正在野外露营，我知道这片荒野的这个区域曾有人目击到熊。所以焦虑实际上会带给我这样的信息：这里既可能有危险，也可能是安全的。然后它用这些信息引导我做好准备，并针对这种潜在危险采取行动，从而最大化我从那只熊手中确保安全的几率，
but something good could also happen. It's still possible. So I might have anxiety, maybe I'm out camping, and I know that there are bears that have been cited in this part of the wilderness. And so anxiety would actually give me the information that there could be danger, but also safety. And then it primes me with that information, it primes me to prepare and to do something about that potential danger and to optimize the chances
并且确保我不会误入一个有母熊和幼崽的洞穴。你知道的，这让我想起了英特尔前CEO安迪·格鲁夫（Andy Grove）的那句名言。他说：在商业中，只有偏执狂才能生存。在某种程度上，这也是同一个道理，不是吗？也就是说，焦虑能让你同时关注威胁与可能性，而关闭你的焦虑在某种程度上就像是拆除你的烟雾报警器，因为它们让你感到心烦意乱。
that I can be safe from that bear. And that I don't wander into a cave where there's a bear with her cups. You know, I'm reminded of that adage from former Intel CEO Andy Grove. He says, in business, only the paranoid survive. And to some extent, it's the same idea, isn't it, which is that anxieties keep you focused on on both threats, but also on possibilities, and turning off your anxiety is in some ways like dismantling your smoke alarms because they feel upsetting to you.
没错。焦虑必须要让人感觉糟糕才能完成它的工作，因为它必须让我们坐直身子并集中注意力。而你提到的烟雾报警器类比，如果我们听到家里的烟雾报警器响了，塞住耳朵或者直接忽略这个信号搬到房子的另一个区域去，显然是不明智的。当我们听到烟雾报警器响时，我们会做的是
That's right. Anxiety actually has to feel bad to do its job because it has to make a sit-up and pay attention. And the smoke alarm analogy you bring up, if we hear a smoke alarm go off in our house, it really wouldn't be wise to put earplugs in, or to just ignore the signal and move to another part of the house. What we do when we hear a smoke alarm
确保没有发生火灾。我们甚至可能会检查电池以确保它没有失灵，但我们绝不会忽视它。而焦虑是一种渴望被倾听、渴望被尊重的感情。它在告诉我们，我们正面临着未来的不确定性，而我在这里是为了帮助你驾驭它。我将为你提供关于即将发生的事情的信息，并让你尽一切可能确保你所期望的结果成为现实。
is we make sure there's not fire. We might even check the batteries to make sure that's not off, but we don't ignore it. An anxiety is an emotion that wants to be heated, that wants to be honored. It's telling us that there's this future uncertainty that we're facing, and I'm here to help you navigate it. I'm going to prepare you with information about what's coming, and to do everything you possibly can to make sure that those outcomes you hope for
当特雷西怀着她的第一个孩子——她的儿子科维时，她想起了焦虑如何能成为她的朋友。我去做了孕中期超声检查，我们发现我的儿子出生时将患有一种名为法洛四联症（tetrology of flow）的先天性心脏病。
become your reality. Tracy was reminded how anxiety could be her friend when she was pregnant with her first child, her son, Kavi. I went in for the mid-pregnancy ultrasound, and we found out that my son was going to be born with a congenital heart condition, called tetrology of flow.
这种疾病需要通过心脏直开手术来修复。伴随这种疾病，你可能会遇到相关的基因异常。你会面临截然不同的结果。我的意思是，孩子们确实能挺过这一关，但有时它可能非常危险。当然，任何时候对婴儿进行心脏直开手术都是非常吓人的。所以我们发现了这一点，我直接爬上床。我感到了极大的痛苦、焦虑，你知道的，还有一点绝望，大哭了一场后，我打开PubMed（医学文献数据库），在几个小时内尽可能多地了解了这种疾病。随后我进行了更多信息的搜集。
And this condition requires open heart surgery to repair it. And with this disease, you can have genetic abnormalities that go along with it. You have very disparate kinds of outcomes. I mean, children do survive this, but sometimes it can be very risky. And of course, anytime you're doing open heart surgery on an infant, it's very frightening. So we found this out and I just crawled into bed. I felt such anguish, anxiety and you know, and a little despair was had a good cry, I got on to PubMed, and I learned within the space of a few hours as much as I could about this disease. I then followed that with more information gathering.
我和我丈夫给认识的每个医生都打了电话。其中几个人碰巧是心脏病专家，他们帮我们弄清楚了：好吧，你需要去找这位外科医生和这个医疗团队。所以我开始意识到，我一直在搜集信息，而且我已经在做准备了。我们实际上得到了一种恩赐，那就是我们在儿子出生前就发现了这种疾病，这样我们就可以尽最大可能做好安排，为他争取到我们所能获得的最好照顾。在某种程度上，你现在将你和
My husband and I called up every doctor we knew. A couple of them happened to be cardiac specialists, and they helped us figure out that, okay, you need to get to this surgeon and this practice. So what I started to realize is I was information gathering and I was already preparing. We were really receiving a blessing that we found out about this disease before my son was born so that we could have things set up as well as possible to get him the best care we could. And in some ways, you now credit your anxiety with helping get you and
家人能够挺过这场手术及其后的恢复归功于你的焦虑？哦，百分之百。我的意思是，我们需要在每个阶段都确保我们安排了适当的照顾，在他出生后我们要进行监测，他会进入心力衰竭状态，这是板上钉钉的事，而他也确实如钟表般准时地在大约一个月大时发病了。然后他出现了发育迟缓。他没有力气母乳喂养或用奶瓶吃奶。所以我们不得不通过一根插进他鼻子的管子给他喂食。那是一段非常具有挑战性的时期。
coming in the family through the surgery and its aftermath? Oh, 100%. I mean, we needed to make sure at every stage that we had the proper care set up, that we were monitoring once he was born, he was going to go into heart failure, that was guaranteed, and he did like kind of like clockwork actually about a month in. He then had failure to thrive. He wasn't strong enough to be able to breastfeed or take a bottle. And so we had to give him food through a tube that was put down his nose. It was very challenging time.
但正是我的焦虑让我专注于这个未来，我知道如果我们竭尽全力，我们就拥有极大的可能性让他安然无恙。所以，这就是那个几年后你告诉他“你需要成为一个勇士、不要再害怕了”的孩子？嗯，我们的心脏病专家确实在手术后告诉过我们，我们绝不能把他当成一个生病的孩子对待，所以你看，我把这话听进去了。所以据我了解，研究人员在心力衰竭的成年患者中也发现了同一种现象的实证？特雷西，这里的焦虑扮演了什么角色？
But it was my anxiety that kept me really focused on this future, where I knew that if we did everything we could, that we had a very strong possibility that he would be just fine. So, this is the same kid who a few years later you were telling you need to be a warrior and stop being afraid. Well, our cardiologist did tell us that after the surgery that we should never treat him like a sick child, so there you go, I took it to heart. So I understand that researchers have found empirical evidence of the same phenomenon
是莫太（Mother）及其同事，他们作为医生和医疗专业人员，对如何真正为那些准备接受心脏移植手术的患者促进积极的健康结果非常感兴趣。常识表明，如果患者有更高的焦虑或抑郁情绪，他们的健康结果可能会更糟糕，他们对心脏移植的反应可能也不会那么好。但他们发现了一个非常有趣的事实。焦虑和抑郁情绪水平较高的患者，实际上拥有更好的健康结果，并且比那些情绪水平较低的患者更有可能接受
among adult patients with heart failure. What is the role of anxiety here, Tracy? It was mother and colleagues who, you know, as doctors and medical professionals, they were very interested in how to really promote positive health outcomes for people who were in line to receive a heart transplant. And so common sense suggests that if a patient has higher anxiety or depression, their health outcomes might be worse and they might not respond as well to the heart transplant. But they found something very interesting. Patients who had higher levels of anxiety and depressed mood actually had better health outcomes and were more likely to receive
移植手术。他们对此的真正解读是，特别是那些焦虑水平较高的患者，他们更能坚持治疗建议。在等待心脏移植期间，他们更规律地看医生。他们在照顾自己以及遵循医生所有建议方面表现得更加焦虑和坚持。在某种程度上这完全说得通，不是吗？我为某事感到焦虑。
a transplant than patients who had lower levels of those emotions. And what they really interpreted this as reflecting was that particularly those patients with higher levels of anxiety, they adhered to treatment recommendations more. They saw their doctor more regularly as they were waiting for the heart transplant. They were a little more anxious and persistent in taking care of themselves and following all the recommendations of their doctors. And in some ways it makes perfect sense, doesn't it? I'm anxious about something.
我的医生说你需要做A、B、C和D来确保这个糟糕的结果不会发生。正是因为我感到焦虑，当我医生告诉我要做这些事时，我才会听得超级仔细，并且我真的会去跟进并完成它们。如果我没有焦虑，想必我就没有那种动力和执行控制力去真正落实医生推荐的那些事情。没错。但当我们谈论焦虑时，我们首先想到的就是：哦，我们最好去抚平它。我们最好立刻让它消失。但当我们把焦虑当作信息来倾听，并用它来促使自己更加专注、更加坚持、知道这件事很重要时——而不是去逃避那些让我们感到不舒服的事情——你可以立刻看到焦虑如何在这些领域成为我们的助力。
My doctor says you need to do ABC and D to make sure this bad outcome doesn't happen. And it's because I'm anxious that I listen super carefully when my doctor tells me to do those things and I actually follow up and do them. If I didn't have the anxiety, presumably I might not have the motivation, the executive control to actually do those things that my doctor is recommending. That's right. But when we talk about anxiety, the first thing we think is, oh, we better sue that. We better immediately make it go away. But when we listen to anxiety as information, and we can use it to say, focus more, persist more, you know, know that this is important. Instead of avoiding what makes us uncomfortable, you can see immediately how anxiety is going to be a help me in these kinds
这里存在某种悖论，特雷西，这种感觉驱使我们许多人想要逃离焦虑，那就是我们在焦虑时感受到的那种难以忍受的不适感。我想我听到你所说的是，正是这种不适感，同时也是焦虑的特质，促使我们去收获它的益处。没错，这就是为什么焦虑必须是不舒服的。我们不仅必须坐直身子并关注它，而且焦虑中还存在所谓的负面强化循环。因此，当我们调动对焦虑的关注时，它会促使我们做好准备、集中注意力，而一旦我们走上正轨、一旦我们融入对话中，
of arenas. There's something of a paradox here, Tracy, the feeling that drives many of us to want to flee from anxiety, which is the excruciating discomfort we feel when we're anxious. I think what I'm hearing you say is that it's this discomfort that is also the feature of anxiety that prompts us to reap its benefits. That's right, and that's why anxiety has to be uncomfortable. Not only do we have to sit up and pay attention to it, but there's what's called a negative reinforcement cycle in anxiety, too. So when we tune into anxiety, it's priming us to prepare, to focus, and once we're on the right track, once we're in the conversation,
或者也许我们提前做了一点准备，焦虑就会自然减弱。这是一种非常强化的体验。所以焦虑的不适感会上升，然后当我们根据焦虑提供的信息采取正确的行动时，焦虑就会自然减弱。这告诉我们，当我们针对焦虑采取行动时，我们会感觉更好，并且我们会继续去做并采取这些行动。这几乎就像是一个指南针，不是吗？它实际上给了你一个方向感，告诉你：你偏离了航线，或者你正在航道上。我喜欢这个比喻，因为我们只会为我们在乎的事感到焦虑。我们不会为对我们不重要的事情感到焦虑。
or maybe we've done a little preparation ahead of time, anxiety naturally diminishes. And that is a very reinforcing experience. So the discomfort of anxiety it rises, and then when we're doing the right things to take actions based on the information anxiety is giving us, then anxiety naturally diminishes. And that tells us that when we take action and response to our anxiety, we feel better and we're going to keep doing and taking those actions. It's almost like a compass isn't it? It's actually giving you a sense of direction to say, you're off course or you are, you're on course. I love that because we're only anxious when we care. We're not anxious about things that don't matter to us.
所以焦虑是一个极好的指南针，它指引我们去关注对我们重要的事情、那些对我们及我们所爱之人的生活有影响的事情。它告诉我们，这也是我们在未来依然能够努力去实现的目标。因此，从这个角度来看，焦虑不仅是重要的信息，它还是至关重要、不可或缺的信息。我们所有人内心都有警报声，但并非所有人都学会了如何正确倾听这些声音。稍后我们再谈。你收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔。
So anxiety is a wonderful compass for pointing us to things that matter to us, that have implications for our lives and the lives of our loved ones. It tells us that it's also something in the future that we believe we can still work towards. So anxiety from that perspective is not only important information, it's essential and crucial information. All of us have voices of alarm inside our heads, but not all of us have learned how to properly listen to those voices. That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
当厨房里的烟雾报警器响起时，警报的强度可能会让人心烦意乱。事实上，警报的强度就是被设计成让人心烦意乱的。它试图让你停下正在做的任何其他事情，去调查烟雾背后是否有火灾。
When a smoke alarm goes off in your kitchen, the intensity of the alarm can be upsetting. In fact, the intensity of the alarm is designed to be upsetting. It's trying to make you stop whatever else you're doing and investigate if there is fire behind the smoke. whatever else you're doing and investigate if there is fire behind the smoke. At City University of New York Hunter College, Tracy Dennis Tawari has found that if we are to reap the benefits of our anxieties, we need to find ways to manage the intense discomfort they generate. Tracy, you've written that anxiety wants to be our friend. It wants to be recognized and acknowledged and listened to and cherished and heated. It feels terrible because it's trying to tell us something important that we draw
在纽约市立大学亨特学院，特雷西·丹尼斯·塔瓦里发现，如果我们想要收获焦虑带来的益处，我们需要找到方法来管理它们产生的强烈不适感。特雷西，你曾写道，焦虑想要成为我们的朋友。它想要被识别、被承认、被倾听、被珍视、被重视。它感觉糟糕透顶，是因为它正试图告诉我们一些重要的事情，这些事情我们需要像一个好朋友通常所做的那样去深入挖掘。
than out here as a good friend often does. You know, we talked earlier about how one school of thought in our culture says you should ignore anxieties and another says you should eliminate threats from your life that make you anxious. In important ways, the emerging scientific picture that you're painting would suggest that both schools of thought are wrong in important ways. Can you elaborate on that, Tracy? As usual, any black and white propositions are not quite right. And I think that's especially the case when it comes to anxiety,
你知道的，我们之前谈到过，我们文化中的一种思想流派认为你应该忽视焦虑，而另一种则认为你应该消除生活中让你感到焦虑的威胁。在重要的方面，你所描绘的新兴科学图景表明，这两种思想流派在许多关键方面都是错误的。特雷西，你能详细谈谈吗？和往常一样，任何非黑即白的命题都不大正确。我认为在面对焦虑时尤其如此，
because this whole, you have to be a warrior, pull yourself up by your own bootstraps approach, ignores the fact that before we can do that, we have to listen to anxiety, we have to tune in and leverage it. And so really the metaphor here is that anxiety and other difficult emotions are like waves. And when you have a wave, it's pushing us forward, but you can drown in a wave. So you have to learn to swim. You have to build skills and the ability to work with these emotions, with these feelings. And so when we talk about anxiety as dangerous, or when we put it the emotion of anxiety in the category of disease, we now are primed to avoid and eradicate those feelings.
因为这种“你必须当个勇士、靠自己的靴带把自己拉起来”的整套方法，忽略了这样一个事实：在我们做到这一点之前，我们必须倾听焦虑，我们必须去调谐并利用它。所以这里的隐喻其实是：焦虑和其他困难情绪就像海浪。当你遇到海浪时，它在推动我们前进，但你也可能会在海浪中溺水。所以你必须学会游泳。你必须建立技能和能力，去与这些情绪、这些感觉共事。因此，当我们把焦虑视为危险，或者当我们把焦虑情绪归入疾病类别时，我们现在就被引导去逃避和根除这些感受。
But we know that anxiety and negative and difficult emotions only are amplified when we avoid it, or we steamroll over them. So I love what you said a second ago, which is that we need to learn to listen to anxiety as a source of information. But of course there are ways of doing that. And there's a way of thinking about this kind of response as a skill that is to be learned. And I want to try and look at some of the different elements
但我们知道，如果我们回避焦虑，或者对它们置之不理，焦虑以及消极困难的情绪只会放大。所以我很喜欢你刚才说的话，也就是我们需要学会把焦虑当作一种信息来源来聆听。但当然，这有相应的应对方法。我们可以把这种反应看作是一种需要学习的技能，我想试着探讨一下这种技能的不同要素。
of this skill. You recently had the opportunity to listen to your own anxiety after having an argument with your daughter and then waking up in the middle of the night, replaying the argument in your mind. Tell me what happened in the middle of the night to you, Tracy. This was one of those early morning worry wake-up calls that I think all of us have experienced. It's usually around 4 a.m. for me. And I woke up with just a yucky feeling.
这种技能的要素。你最近在和女儿吵架后，半夜醒来，脑海里不断重播那场争吵，这让你有机会聆听自己的焦虑。翠西，告诉我那天半夜你发生了什么。这是那种清晨因焦虑而醒来的经历，我想我们所有人都经历过。对我来说，通常是在凌晨4点左右。我醒来时只有一种糟糕的感觉。
And when you apply this idea that anxiety is actually information, it primes you to do what I actually tried to do in the moment. I took a breath. I had these free-floating thoughts and worries. And I just waited for a moment. I waited for something to rise to the surface. And what I found when I took that breath and gave anxiety a moment is that this disagreement,
而当你运用“焦虑其实就是信息”这个观点时，它会促使你去做我当时真正尝试做的事情。我深吸了一口气。脑海里闪现着这些无端出现的想法和担忧。我只是等待了一会儿。我等待着有什么浮现到脑海表面。我发现，当我深吸一口气并给焦虑一点时间时，前一天晚上我和女儿的这场争执、
this fight really that I had with my daughter the night before was on my mind. And she'd been upset about something and did something I really wasn't happy about. And I'd yelled at her, you know, and it was bothering me. So when you listen to anxiety, the great thing about this information is that it can prime you to take action. And so I decided right there, as I'm sort of half a week, that I was going to say two or three things that I felt would really address the mistakes I'd made the night before.
这场争吵确实占据了我的脑海。她当时为某事感到不安，并做了一件我很不高兴的事。你知道的，我向她吼了，这一直困扰着我。所以，当你聆听焦虑时，这种信息的妙处在于它能促使你采取行动。因此，我当时就决定，趁着自己处于半梦半醒状态，我要说两三句话，我觉得这些话能真正解决我前一天晚上犯下的错误。
And once I made this plan, even though I was half asleep, I noticed that my anxiety immediately started going down. I started to relax. It was a signal to me that I was on the right track that this is the action that I need to take. And yeah, this was the worry that woke me up. And in some ways, your experience is demonstrating, I think, the importance of making a plan when we're dealing with anxiety, not just simply thinking about it, worrying about it, but actually coming up with concrete, positive things that we can do. That's right, and that's really how we leverage anxiety, because if anxiety is information and preparation, we need to then put that preparation into action.
一旦我制定了这个计划，尽管我还在半睡半醒中，我注意到我的焦虑立刻开始下降。我开始放松了。这对我来说是一个信号，表明我走对了路，这就是我需要采取的行动。是的，这就是把我唤醒的担忧。在某种程度上，你的经历表明，我认为在应对焦虑时制定计划非常重要，不只是单纯地去想它、担心它，而是真正提出我们能采取的具体、积极的行动。没错，这正是我们利用焦虑的方式，因为如果焦虑是信息和准备工作，我们就需要把这种准备工作付诸行动。
and preparation, we need to then put that preparation into action. Once you've either taken an action or maybe figured out there's not that much action you can take, we can in those moments do something that can allow us to be back in the present moment, whether that's, you know, taking some deep breaths, you know, try to relax a little bit, or taking a walk, speaking with a therapist, exercising. These are all things that in this cycle of anxiety, in this learning how to ride the wave of anxiety, these are skills that we can build, even when we're struggling with very strong or debilitating anxiety. Another thing that can help us listen to anxiety without allowing it to destabilize us, in other words, too, as you're in your metaphor to sort of ride the wave or swim the wave
以及准备工作，我们需要将这种准备工作付诸行动。一旦你采取了行动，或者可能发现其实没有什么行动可采取，在那些时刻，我们可以做一些事情来让自己回到当下，无论是做几次深呼吸，试着稍微放松一下，还是散散步、和治疗师聊聊、锻炼身体。这些都是在焦虑的循环中，在学习如何驾驭焦虑之浪的过程中，我们可以培养的技能，即使在我们正与非常强烈或使人衰弱的焦虑作斗争时也是如此。另一件能帮助我们聆听焦虑而不让其动摇我们的事情——换句话说，就像你的比喻那样，去驾驭海浪或在海浪中游泳
as opposed to being drowned by the wave, is social support. Can you talk about this idea that we can help others listen to their alarms and others can help us listen to our alarms if we are giving and receiving social support? It may surprise people to find that anxiety and our social instincts are actually very closely bound. One way that anxiety is linked up with social connection is that when we're anxious, it actually increases levels of oxytocin. In our bodies, an oxytocin is the social bonding hormone, which primes us to seek out social connection.
而不是被海浪淹没——那就是社会支持。你能谈谈这个观点吗：如果我们给予和接受社会支持，我们可以帮助别人聆听他们的警报，别人也能帮助我们聆听我们的警报？人们可能会惊讶地发现，焦虑和我们的社交本能其实联系非常紧密。焦虑与社会联系挂钩的一个方式是，当我们感到焦虑时，它实际上会提高体内催产素的水平。在我们体内，催产素是一种社会联结荷尔蒙，它促使我们去寻求社会联系。
And so our brains actually evolve to outsource emotional challenge to draw on the tribe on our social networks to actually cope with anxiety and stress and all these things. And we do better when we're in social groups. And so in some ways, anxiety with this sort of beautiful fractal symmetry almost contains some of its own solutions within itself.
所以我们的大脑实际上已经进化到将情感挑战外包出去，利用部落和我们的社会网络来真正应对焦虑、压力和所有这些事情。当我们处于社交群体中时，我们表现得更好。因此在某种程度上，带有这种美丽的几何对称性的焦虑，几乎在其自身内部就包含了一些自身的解决方案。
There was a study out of the University of Wisconsin some years ago, I believe, where volunteers were told they were about to receive electrical shocks as they were put into a loud claustrophobic MRI machine. But some of the volunteers were allowed to hold the hands of their loved ones and others were not. Tell me about that study and what it found, Tracy. They have three conditions where people were assigned to either be alone during this difficult and anxiety-provoking task to hold the hand of a stranger or to hold the hand of a loved one. And then what they did because they were already in the MRI machine is they imaged the activity of the anxiety-related circuits in the brain. These areas of the brain that
几年前威斯康星大学做过一项研究，我没记错的话，当时志愿者被带到一个嘈杂、幽闭恐怖的核磁共振机器中，并被告知他们即将受到电击。但一些志愿者被允许握着所爱之人的手，而另一些则没有。翠西，请告诉我关于这项研究以及它的发现。他们设置了三种情况：人们被分配在这次艰难且引发焦虑的任务中独自一人、握着陌生人的手，或是握着所爱之人的手。然后他们所做的是，因为受试者已经在核磁共振机中了，他们拍摄了大脑中与焦虑相关的回路的活动。大脑的这些区域
are activated when we're trying to cope with this challenge in monitor threats. And folks who were alone, that circuit in the brain was working very hard. It was kind of lighting up when you looked at the FMRI readout. And then you had the people who were holding the hand of a stranger. And what you saw is that this circuit in the brain seemed to be somewhat soothed. It was actually less active, a little more efficient. And then, of course, what you saw in the group that was allowed to hold the hand of a loved one is that the anxious brain, so to speak, the circuit that should have been highly activated was much calmer, was well-regulated, and was really operating very efficiently. And I think they also found in this study that the closer your relationship or the more
在我们试图应对这一挑战和监测威胁时会被激活。对于独自一人的参与者，大脑中的那个回路在非常努力地工作。当你查看功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）读数时，它有点像是在亮起。然后是那些握着陌生人手的人。你所看到的是，大脑中的这个回路似乎在一定程度上得到了抚慰。它的活动实际上减少了，效率更高一点。然后，当然，你在被允许握着所爱之人手的那个组中看到的是，焦虑的大脑——可以说是本该高度激活的回路——要平静得多，得到了很好的调节，而且运作得非常高效。我想他们在这项研究中还发现，关系越亲密，或者关系
satisfying your relationship, the stronger this effect was of holding the hand of a loved one. I understand that in your own life, your family experienced a crisis that called upon you to exercise what you had learned about the science of anxiety. Your husband's career faced a sudden challenge some time ago. Tell me about that, what happened to him, and how you responded Tracy. My husband is a Broadway producer, as well as across other platforms. And he had spent the past decade launching with his whole team, bringing to Broadway and Lana's Morissette's Jagged Little Pill. And this was really this huge achievement. It was highly anticipated and wonderfully received musical.
越让人满意，握着所爱之人的手所产生的这种效果就越强烈。据我所了解，在你自己的生活中，你的家人经历了一场危机，这场危机要求你运用你所学到的关于焦虑科学的知识。一段时间前，你丈夫的职业生涯面临了突然的挑战。请告诉我这件事，他身上发生了什么，以及你是如何应对的，翠西。我丈夫是百老汇的制作人，同时也涉足其他平台。过去十年里，他和整个团队一直在筹备，将阿兰尼斯·莫里塞特（Alanis Morissette）的《小碎药丸》（Jagged Little Pill）搬上百老汇舞台。这确实是一项巨大的成就。这是一部备受期待且广受好评的音乐剧。
And about four months later, the pandemic happened. And so this decade of work, you know, this passion project was now closed down. And of course, it was very much out of our control, as we all experienced during the pandemic, these kinds of changes. And as he was struggling, I found that I myself was struggling really a lot with handling my own anxiety about what the future held for his career for our family, but also struggling with how to help him work through this very real uncertainty and anxiety. One thing that I did is I tried to just be a listening ear to what he was going through
大约四个月后，大流行爆发了。因此，这十年的工作，你知道的，这个倾注热情的项目现在被迫关停了。当然，这很大程度上超出了我们的控制，就像我们在大流行期间所有人经历的那样，这种类型的变化。当他在苦苦挣扎时，我发现我自己其实也在极力应对自己对他的职业生涯、对我们的家庭未来的焦虑，同时也在苦苦挣扎于如何帮他度过这种非常现实的不确定性和焦虑。我做的一件事就是试着做一个倾听者，去听听他正在经历的事情，
and to suspend judgment, really. As a psychologist, maybe just as my personality, I'm a problem solver. I like to go in, I like to fix it. And you know that's also a great anxiety management tool. So, but here I am, and I know that there's not really anything we can do right now. This is, there's some things that are uncontrollable, and right now what he needed to do was process what he was going through before he could take any action. And so really my task was to suspend judgment, suspend this impulse to solve problems.
并且真正地悬置判断。作为一名心理学家，或者也许只是出于我的性格，我是一个问题解决者。我喜欢介入其中，我喜欢去解决问题。你知道这也是一个极好的焦虑管理工具。所以，但现在我在这里，我知道我们现在其实无能为力。有些事情是无法控制的，而他现在需要做的是在采取任何行动之前，先消化他正在经历的事情。所以我的任务实际上是悬置判断，悬置这种急于解决问题的冲动。
And when we got through those early stages of worry and loss and all those feelings, he ended up actually going in a different professional direction that has been immensely beneficial and satisfying to him. But it's also the case, I think, you know, your response to him was different than your response to your son. And I'm trying to understand how and why that happened. And I think what I'm hearing in some ways is that, you know, when your son was expressing
当我们熬过那些早期的担忧、失落和所有这些情绪之后，他最终实际上走向了另一个对他的职业生涯大有裨益且让他非常满足的职业方向。但情况也是如此，我想，你知道，你对他的回应与你对儿子的回应是不同的。我正试图理解这是如何以及为什么发生的。我想我在某种程度上听到的是，当你的儿子表达
these concerns, in some ways you were catastrophizing about how, you know, his concerns about riding a bike might affect him later as an adult, and you were, you were spiraling. And instead of simply listening to your anxiety and saying, let me take in this information and see what to do with it, you were trying to get rid of the anxiety as quickly as possible by telling him that he shouldn't be afraid. And with your husband, it sounds like you were better able to say, yes, it's uncomfortable, yes, this is anxiety provoking. Yes, I'm a problem solver and this is a problem I cannot solve.
这些担忧时，在某种程度上你在灾难化地看待这些事情，比如他骑自行车的担忧可能会如何在以后成年时影响他，而你的思维陷入了恶性循环。你没有单纯地去倾听你的焦虑并说：“让我吸收这些信息，看看该怎么处理它”，而是试图通过告诉他不应该害怕，来尽快摆脱焦虑。而对于你丈夫，听起来你更能说：是的，这让人不舒服，是的，这会引发焦虑。是的，我是一个问题解决者，而这是一个我无法解决的问题。
But you were patient enough to sit with the discomfort. And surprisingly, this was actually what your husband needed. I think it's just what you say. My anxiety for my son was so great, but it was prefaced on this idea that he was fragile in some way, that I couldn't control. And I think I had a level of belief in faith that my husband had what it took to go through this, that I think allowed me to do better as a partner to my husband in that moment than I did for my son.
但你有足够的耐心去忍受这种不舒服。出人意料的是，这实际上正是你丈夫所需要的。我想这正如你所说。我对儿子的焦虑太大了，但它的前提是认为他在某种程度上是脆弱的，而这是我无法控制的。我想我对丈夫拥有度过难关的能力有一种信念和信任，这让我觉得在那个时刻，我作为伴侣对丈夫的表现要好过我对儿子的表现。
So Tracy, I can imagine that there are people who have anxiety disorders, clinically diagnosed anxiety disorders, who would say, hang on a second, what I have is a medical, biological, psychiatric problem, and that's not going to get fixed by merely following Tracy's advice to listen to anxiety as information. What would you say to these people? I really honor that perspective because what we do know about anxiety is that there are many, many causes of anxiety disorders. There are many biological and medical causes that can make our struggles with anxiety much, much worse. And these vary from
所以翠西，我可以想象，有些人患有焦虑症，即临床诊断的焦虑症，他们会说：“等一下，我得的是医学上的、生物学上的、精神病学上的问题，这可不是仅仅遵循翠西‘把焦虑当作信息来聆听’的建议就能解决的。”你会对这些人说些什么呢？我非常尊重这种观点，因为我们对焦虑的了解是，焦虑症有很多很多成因。有许多生物学和医学原因会使我们与焦虑的斗争变得更加糟糕。这些原因因人而异，包括
nutrition, lifestyle choices, and even the over-prescription of medications, including benzodiazepines, which over time, we know can actually increase baseline levels of anxiety, unfortunately. So I acknowledge that there are many, many determinants and factors of anxiety disorders. At the same time, by being curious and open to anxiety, understanding that it's information to listen to
营养、生活方式的选择，甚至是药物的过度使用，包括苯二氮卓类药物，不幸的是，随着时间的推移，我们知道这些药物实际上会提高基线焦虑水平。所以我承认焦虑症有很多很多的决定因素和影响因素。与此同时，通过对焦虑保持好奇和开放的心态，理解它是需要倾听的信息，
and to leverage and then to gain skills and letting go, that stance can actually help us tune into when there might be these biological and lifestyle factors that are leading to debilitating anxiety. It can help us benefit more from therapies when we do receive them. And I think it can help us also have more hope and believe that anxiety and feeling anxiety it doesn't indicate that we're broken or that we have a malfunction or failure.
并加以利用，然后获得放下的技能，这种态度实际上可以帮助我们敏锐地察觉到，什么时候可能是这些生物学和生活方式因素导致了使人衰弱的焦虑。当我们接受治疗时，它可以帮助我们从治疗中获益更多。而且我认为它还可以帮助我们拥有更多希望，相信焦虑和感受到焦虑并不表明我们坏掉了，或者我们出现了功能失调或失败。
But rather that it's really part of this messy work of being human, and we can gain skills and we can find solutions. So I think this stands, if taken in the spirit that I hope it's received, it can really be empowering to people, even who are suffering from debilitating anxiety. I understand that you have a story of how you once initially pursue this tough love warrior model that you pursued with your son.
相反，它其实是身为人这件纷繁复杂工作的一部分，我们可以获得技能，我们可以找到解决方案。因此我认为，如果以我所希望的这种精神来接受这种态度，它真的可以赋予人们力量，即使是那些正在遭受严重焦虑折磨的人。我知道你有一个故事，讲的是你最初如何奉行那种与儿子一样的“严厉之爱”的战士模式。
You also pursued it with your daughter, Nandini, before recalibrating. Can you tell me how you initially responded to her fear of insects and how that changed over time, Tracy? So, this was after the bike riding incident. You think I would have learned, but. So, so this was, I think within that first year of the pandemic, she was about seven or eight at the time. And my daughter, Nandini, was a girl who loved being out in nature, she had taken part in these eco science camps
你在对女儿南迪尼（Nandini）时也奉行过这种模式，后来才重新调整。翠西，你能讲讲你最初是如何应对她对昆虫的恐惧的，以及这种态度随着时间是如何改变的吗？所以，这是在骑自行车事件之后。你以为我会吸取教训，但是。所以，这大约是在大流行发生的头一年里，她当时大约七八岁。我的女儿南迪尼是一个喜欢大自然的女孩，她曾参加过这些生态科学夏令营，
where she just had bugs crawling over her all the time. And now here we are in the pandemic and all of a sudden, she's expressing a lot of concerns and anxieties about insects and particular flies and ladybugs were her, were her bugaboo's. And I knew that around ages eight and nine, a lot of kids actually start to develop new fears. And so I even had this framework, okay, this is expected.
在那里她身上总是爬满了虫子。而现在我们经历了疫情，突然之间，她表达了对昆虫的很多担忧和焦虑，特别是苍蝇和瓢虫成了她的心病。我知道在八九岁左右，许多孩子确实开始产生新的恐惧。所以我当时甚至有这样的框架：好吧，这是意料之中的。
But one day day we were in the bathroom, and I think she was brushing her teeth, and there was a fly, a big fly that got stuck in the bathroom. And she screamed at the top of her lungs. And so I in my mind decided, okay, now's the time to expose her to this fear of bugs, and we'll work through it. And I'm going to be a great parent. So I closed the door and locked it. She's banging on the door and I'm sort of trying to talk to her and say no we need to you know let's catch the fly and put it outside and she wasn't in a sort of low or moderate state of anxiety. She was really panicking and she and she'll tell me this now to this day that she actually thinks that was the moment
但有一天我们在浴室里，我想她当时在刷牙，浴室里有一只苍蝇，一只大苍蝇被困在里面。她放声尖叫。于是在我脑海里，我决定：好吧，现在是让她接触对虫子的这种恐惧的时候了，我们要克服它。我要做一个伟大的家长。所以我把门关上并锁上了。她在使劲拍门，我则试着跟她说话，告诉她“不，我们需要，你知道的，把苍蝇抓起来放到外面去”。她当时并不是处于轻度或中度的焦虑状态。她真的恐慌了，直到今天她还会告诉我，她实际上认为那是她真正开始害怕虫子的时刻，
that she became really scared of bugs because Mama locked her in the bathroom with a fly. No, luckily it's not the end of the story. So, and I acknowledged that this was not the most productive way to work through her anxiety. And so what I started doing, and really again, and sort of collaboration with her was talk about her anxieties, her, you know, what was it about? Insects, you know, I think I should have gotten a little more Freudian and thought, huh, we're in the middle of a pandemic where there's this virus, which we think of as a bug, and it's put the entire world off-kilter, and she's developed a fear of bugs. But anyway, I really, as I course corrected, tried to talk with her more and make a plan to say,
因为妈妈把她和一只苍蝇锁在浴室里。不，幸运的是，这不是故事的结局。所以，我承认这不是克服她焦虑的最有效方法。于是我开始做的，再次真正地，是与她合作来讨论她的焦虑、她的、你知道的，这究竟是怎么回事？昆虫，你知道的，我想我本该更弗洛伊德一点，心想：哈，我们正处于一场大流行病中，有一种我们认为是“虫子（病毒）”的病毒，它把整个世界弄得底朝天，而她却对虫子产生了恐惧。不管怎样，当我纠正航向时，我真的试着与她多沟通，并制定一个计划：
listen, we're going to be around bugs. They're inescapable. How can we get you gradually to be more comfortable with bugs? And so, you know, we'd spend a little time in that area where we saw some bugs. We talked about strategies she could use to calm herself when she felt anxious about those bugs. And we sort of took this gradual exposure approach.
“听着，我们要和虫子生活在一起。它们是不可避免的。我们如何能让你逐渐对虫子感到习惯呢？”所以，你知道的，我们会花一点时间在我们看到一些虫子的那个区域。我们讨论了当她对那些虫子感到焦虑时可以用来平静自己的策略。我们采用了这种循序渐进的接触方法。
And then just this past summer, her heart was set on attending a camp with some of her friends up in Maine. Now, this would be in the middle of the woods, on a lake in Maine, which equals bugs, many, many bugs. But now she had this real passion and motivation to try to figure this out. And so we talked about, okay,
然后就在今年夏天，她铁了心要去缅因州参加一个有她一些朋友陪伴的夏令营。这可是位于缅因州湖畔的森林深处，这意味着虫子，非常非常多的虫子。但现在她有了强烈的热情和动力去想方设法解决这个问题。所以我们讨论了，好吧，
there are going to be bugs there. What kinds of bugs do you think you'll see? How do you think you might feel? If you feel anxious, how do you want to work with that anxiety? How can you cope with it? And we sort of made this plan, but then she went and she wasn't she was feeling nervous. When she got there, she wanted to be part of the fun. And she soon realized that if she was too afraid to get into the lake because the bugs that
那里会有虫子。你觉得你会看到什么样的虫子？你觉得自己会有什么感觉？如果你感到焦虑，你想如何应对这种焦虑？你如何应对它？我们制定了这个计划，然后她去了，虽然她感到紧张。当她到达那里时，她想融入大家的乐趣中。她很快意识到，如果她因为那里可能有虫子而害怕下水，她就会错过获得徽章、游泳和与朋友们在一起的机会。所以她真的非常积极地开始克服这一点，不久之后。
might be there, she would be missing out on getting badges and swimming and being with her friends. And so she literally just started working on it very actively and pretty soon. She was the one who was first in the lake. And when we picked her up a few weeks later, she said, want to swim in a pool. Pools are boring lakes. I'm a lake swimming girl. Tracy Dennis Tawari is a psychologist and neuroscientist at CUNY Hunter College. She's the author of Future Tense, why anxiety is good for you, even though it feels bad. Tracy, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
她成了第一个下湖的人。几周后我们去接她时，她说：“我想去泳池游泳。泳池太无聊了，湖泊才是我的最爱，我是个属于湖泊的游泳女孩。”翠西·丹尼斯-蒂瓦里（Tracy Dennis-Tiwari）是纽约城市大学亨特学院（CUNY Hunter College）的心理学家和神经科学家。她著有《将来时：为什么焦虑对你有益，尽管感觉很糟糕》（Future Tense: Why Anxiety Is Good for You, Even Though It Feels Bad）。翠西，谢谢你今天来到“隐藏的大脑”（Hidden Brain）。
Thank you so much, Shankar. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Brigitte McCarthy, Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. For today's UnSunk Hero, we turn the mic over to you, our listeners. This segment is brought to you by OnStar. OnStar advisors are now with you everywhere, on the app, in your car, and at home. Today's story comes from Alexandra Middlewood.
非常感谢你，尚卡尔。“隐藏的大脑”由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布丽吉特·麦卡锡（Brigitte McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲·保罗（Annie Murphy Paul）、克里斯滕·黄（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是“隐藏的大脑”的执行主编。今天的“无名英雄”，我们把麦克风交给你，我们的听众。本环节由安吉星（OnStar）赞助播出。安吉星顾问现在随时随地陪伴着你，无论是在应用程序上、车内还是家中。今天的讲述者来自亚历山德拉·米德尔伍德（Alexandra Middlewood）。
She's a professor of political science at Wichita State University. During the fall 2021 semester, Alexandra began hybrid teaching, with some of her students in masks in front of her, others on Zoom. So, wearing a mask for a 75-minute lecture, while wearing a microphone, while trying to make sure that my students who are on Zoom are engaged, my students who are in the classroom are engaged, while also trying to, you know, navigate PowerPoint
她是威奇托州立大学（Wichita State University）的政治学教授。在2021年秋季学期，亚历山德拉开始进行混合式教学，她面前的一些学生戴着口罩，另一些则通过 Zoom 上课。所以，戴着口罩讲课75分钟，同时戴着麦克风，还要努力确保我在 Zoom 上的学生参与进来，在教室里的学生参与进来，同时还要努力，你知道的，操作幻灯片
and my own lecture notes and writing key concepts on the board, I don't know how I'm going to do this all semester. I don't know how I'm going to try to navigate teaching to two classrooms essentially. One Monday morning, three weeks into the semester, Alexandra was feeling especially overwhelmed. So I was lecturing on the material. I had just finished writing something on the whiteboard and I turned around and I looked up and I have this room full of students. You know most of them are you know, maybe not as engaged as I would like and I noticed there's this one student who is notting
和我的讲课笔记，并在黑板上写下核心概念，我不知道自己该怎么撑过这整个学期。我不知道自己该如何应对同时向两个“教室”授课的情况。学期开始三周后的一个周一早晨，亚历山德拉感到格外不知所措。所以我当时正在讲授内容。我刚在白板上写完一些东西，然后转过身抬头一看，我看到满屋子的学生。你知道的，他们大部分人，你知道的，可能并不像我希望的那样投入，然后我注意到有这么一个学生在
along with what I'm saying and looking directly at me. And not just nodding in a way to signal that he's paying attention, but nodding emphatically in a way, at least that it seemed to me that what I was trying to teach was resonating with him and his life experiences and that he was understanding these concepts.
随着我讲的内容点头，并且直视着我。不仅仅是以一种示意他在注意听讲的方式点头，而是以一种强有力的方式用力点头，至少在我看来，我试图教授的内容引起了他和他生活经历的共鸣，并且他正在理解这些概念。
And then I felt really reinvigorated. And it was the most excited I had been to be there in a classroom for a really long time. I remember thinking to myself, this, I've really missed this. this. I've really missed this. This right here is why I love my job. And I hope that students will now be able to do that for their professors. And even those of us who, you know, we sit in meetings for work all the time, we can now think about what little gestures like nodding may mean to someone who's presenting material to us or who's leading a meeting or whatever that situation may be. Political science professor Alexandra Middlwood, she lives in Wittaker, Kansas. This segment was brought to you by OnStar.
然后我感到重新焕发了活力。这是我很久以来在教室里感受到的最激动的一次。我记得当时心里在想：“这个，我真的很怀念这个。这个，我真的很怀念这个。此时此刻正是我热爱我的工作的原因。”我希望学生们现在也能为他们的教授们做到这一点。甚至我们这些，你知道的，整天坐在会议室里开会的人，现在也可以想想，像点头这样的小动作对于向我们展示材料或主持会议的人来说可能意味着什么，无论当时的情况如何。政治学教授亚历山德拉·米德尔伍德，她住在堪萨斯州的维多利亚。本环节由安吉星赞助播出。
OnStar believes everyone has the right to feel safe everywhere. That's why their emergency advisors are now available to help, not only in the car, but wherever you are. On your phone, in your car, and at home. OnStar, be safe out there. If you liked this episode and would like us to produce more shows like this, please consider supporting our work. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, if you find our work to be useful in your life, do your part to help us thrive. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
安吉星坚信每个人都有权利在任何地方感到安全。这就是为什么他们的紧急求助顾问现在随时待命，不仅在车里，无论你在哪里都能提供帮助。在你的手机上、车内和家中。安吉星，出行平安。如果你喜欢这一集，并希望我们制作更多类似的节目，请考虑支持我们的工作。访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。再次强调，如果你发现我们的工作对你的生活有帮助，请尽你的一份力来帮助我们蓬勃发展。访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。我们回头见。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。